it's a great pleasure to have anthony
leviera here
he's um
anthony got his phd from
paris in 2009 and he's currently at
indriya
he's
i think he's
he's worked uh extensively you know on
quantum coding um
uh so he's um he's worked on quantum
expander codes on fault tolerance with
uh
achieving fault tolerance with constant
overhead and um
you know most recently of course he's
been working on uh low density parity
check uh quotes uh quantum quantum ldp
sequence so
um and um uh there are of course um
a lot of advances in the field in this
in these last couple of years a number
of breakthroughs so
um
uh really looking forward to hearing
your your talk about these
company
thank you thanks thanks for the
invitation thanks everyone for coming
um yeah so today i want to
to talk about you know recent you know
exciting developments in the field of
quantum ldpc codes
and particularly the discovery of good
quantitative sequence which will be kind
of the end of the talk and it's
christian breakthrough by patrick and
karachar
and
the goal of the talk is to introduce you
to to this field of quarter mldpc coding
and
why is it important and and to present
the the recent developments in this
field
but before i do that let me start more
gently with classical coding
some reminder so i mean it's been known
since the 50s since the work of shannon
that if you want to send you know
reliable information on a noisy
noisy classical channel what you should
do is to use rebellion but then
basically if you want to send k bits of
information what you should do is to
somehow encode them into a larger
message of length m
in such a way that even if you have some
noise then if you have some bit flips on
your message then you can correct for
these bit flips
um and the way to do that
is to use a this called a code so a code
a linear code will be just a
linear subspace of
the space of n b strings
and the way we define it so we have our
n bits x 1 x 2 up to x n
and the way we define a linear subspace
is just by using you know parent check
equations so maybe you say x 1 plus x 2
plus x three distributes there you have
to sum to zero and two x three plus x
four plus x six you have two sum two
zero and two and you you give a list of
i check equations like this
and then your code space
is just you know um the the space of all
the worlds of the end words x such that
hx equals zero where h is this matrix
that
that gives you these parity check
equations so h is called the parity
check matrix
the code is nothing but the kernel of
this matrix
um
so okay so the code is a kernel you have
a code of length n that encodes k bits
so k is the dimension of the code
and and the the third important
parameter for codes for coding theory is
the distance of the code okay so when
you have a code like this you don't want
it to be arbitrary you want it you want
to you know design it in such a way that
every code word is far away from every
other code world
for the aiming metric okay you want that
you're able to flip many bits you have a
large error and you're still able to
correct for it
okay so the distance of the code
is just you know the minimum distance
between two
different code words
or because everything is linear here
is just the minimum arming weight
of a non-zero code word x
okay and we have these three parameters
so the length and
the dimension k
and the the distance d okay so you need
to collect this n k d
um
and so
the goal of the field is usually to find
codes
such that the rate so the ratio between
k and n the number of logical bits per
physical bits is as large as possible
and you want good correction
capabilities you want to be able to
collect
large errors
and so if you want to what is an error
an error is just a again a bit string an
n bit string e that will tell you where
which bits are flipped
okay and when you have an error of
course you cannot observe the audio key
what you observe is x plus b so the
codeword that you send
code wordpress plus e
and what you can compute is the syndrome
of the error so you can compute h
applied to x plus e and gives you h
times e because h of x equals zero
okay so s thing is a syndrome
and the the decoding problem is the the
following you're given a syndrome
whenever you're given a syndrome and
what you want to do is to recover the
error e of minimum weight such that h
times equal s
okay and in general this is a problem
it's np art
if you have an ability code linear code
so you will want to design codes for
which this problem becomes easy
and so there are two kind of regimes of
interest you have the kind of the
theoretical computer science regime
where you you want to consider you know
adversarial errors
and then the only thing that counts is
somehow the distance of the code because
if you have an error of weight less less
than d over two then in principle you
can recover the you can look at the
closest code word and this will give you
you know
the
the correct the current solution
and the other regime that is more
relevant in practice is that of random
errors okay so maybe the maybe the
distance is not so good but the errors
that will you know take advantage of
this small distance they are very
unlikely and on the mirrors you can
correct efficiency so this is also
interesting
um and so one class of um you know
classical codes and that has been uh you
know very fashionable
uh so it's ldpc codes so this goes were
invented a long time ago by gallagher in
his phd
like in 63 and then they were forgotten
for 30 years because at that time so
gallagher invented this cause he
explained how to decode them but at that
time we didn't have the computational
power to really use them in practice so
people really forgot about those and
then they were already discovered in the
90s
and so these classical ldpc codes were
whether they are exactly what i've said
so linear codes um
but with the special property that the
the graph here which is called the tenor
graph so that you know with the bits on
one side and the body checks on the
other side this graph should be sparse
okay so the degree of the
of this graph of this graph should be
constant
and when you have that you have what you
call
ldpc code so ldbc stands for low density
parity check matrix okay so we have a
parity check matrix h
which is low density which is sparse so
the number of ones per row and that
column
is a constant independent of n
so what is nice with this code is that
if you take just a random h which is a
random sparse matrix h and with high
probability you will get what is called
a good code
meaning that k and d both scale linearly
with n okay so just do that you get a
good code
in the quantum case it's not at all like
this we don't know how to get good codes
like this
so okay so good codes are easy to get
but what is more important is to get
efficient decoding algorithms
and if you have an
ldbc code then you have this parse graph
and then there's a way to exploit
dispersity to you know design good
decoders
so you can design good decoders in
theory and that will work well against
the versailles
this was the you know the celebrated
work of steve's parents sister and
speedman in 96 exponentials
and they also work well in practice you
know in practice you have decoders
called belief propagation
that work tremendously well
and these codes they are very successful
they are applied everywhere they are
used in wi-fi in 5g okay so in the
classical case
we know we understand very well
classical and dpc codes
and okay so it's easy to find good codes
like this
and we can design efficient decoding
algorithms
with proven
properties and that performance
okay so now let's move to really really
what we care about today is quantum
codes okay so what's the difference
between a classical and quantum code um
it's not that big
so you know in classical coding you have
basically one type of errors the only
errors that can occur are b trips okay
bt slips zero goes to one one goes to
zero
in the golden case you have essentially
two types of errors you have big flips
again and you have new errors which are
face flips
okay and basically if you
because of linearity of quantum
mechanics you you can show that if you
can correct your bit flips and phase
flips then you can crack the basic
okay so in a sense we only care about
these two types of errors
and
so we have two types of errors so what
is the solution we need two classical
codes one will
you know take care of bit flips and the
other one will take care of phase shifts
um
so you know and kind of very roughly
codon code is nothing but two classical
codes but these two classical codes they
cannot be a bit high they need to
satisfy some properties
um and the properties that they need
satisfy is the following so
so now the parity checks that we have
before they they are a bit you know some
are upgraded they are not just
you know party checks they are really
operators
so we have two types of operators we
have x type
parity checks and that type parity
checks so this one will you know this
will be polyoperators
that apply
polyx
operators in each qubits and this one
will be
products of that for the operators
and what you want to define a quantum
code is you want that the
you know all the all these checks they
should commute pairwise because some of
the the quantum code will be the
the common eigen subspace
with eigenvalue one of all these checks
so really what you need is that these
checks they commute pairwise
so this means that if you look at their
overlap so if you look at the you know
the support of this check
um
this part of this check it's just these
four blue cubes so the qubits are in the
middle
the checks the x checks are on the left
z checks on the right
so if you look at the spot of this one
you have this four cubits if you look at
the support of this
z check you have these four q bits
and if you want these two checks to
commute it means that that support
should develop
on an even number of positions so here
it's finally overlapped here and here
um
and in this case for this code is called
the steam code okay it can encode seven
qubits you have
one logical qubit so you have a subspace
you know including one logical cubit
your distance three and
but okay so so you need these checks to
come in pair why so what does it mean
um
so it means so if you have
you know so you want to define these two
classical codes
for each type of errors so x would be
the kernel of the matrix h x c z will be
the canal of some matrix h z
and this you know commutation condition
can be rested as follows it's just h x
times h z transpose should be zero
side otherwise equivalently you can say
that in this code in cx
you should have
the dual of cz so what is the dual of cz
is just the code
generated
you know product of z checks
and gives you a word of
d pairs and all these words they should
belong to cx
next we have these three equivalent
conditions and this is really the
novelty in the cotton case okay you're
gonna take arbitrary because you need
this commutation
condition
and then okay so you
you can define things as before so the
length of the code is just the number of
physical qubits and
this will define
the code we define
a subspace of dimension two to the k
that can cause k logical cubits
so you have an upper bound lower than k
which is just n number of physical
qubits minus the number of different
checks
and kind of the novelty is the distance
the distance of the code now you have
you know you have two classical codes
you have two distances you want to be
able to correct for x errors and z
errors so you have dx and dz
and dx is not exactly the distance of cx
because in cx in this code you know you
have
you have all the z checks that belong
to cx for the z checks it belongs to cx
but the z checks they stabilize the
codewords so they don't make an error so
they don't count in some sense so really
the distance the x distance
is the minimum you know weight
of a poly error or
a world that belongs to cx but that is
not you know
the sum of checks of such apps
and similarly dz the second distance is
the minimum weight of a word that
belongs to c z and it is not
a sum of x checks
okay
and then we have the same kind of
notation that's in the particular case
with these double brackets yeah the nkd
code
that can cause you know you have any
physical qubits geological qubits which
are protected and distance d
and just as in the classical
case you can define ldpc codes and this
will be called for which hx and hz with
super hypnotics are sparse
but in that case you
one very important observation is that
cx and cz these two classical codes they
are not good
they are not good because cx as i said
already it contains many it contains all
the z type checks which have constant
weight
which are ldpc
so cx contains many words of constant
weight so this is not a good chord the
distance is
you know the distance of cx
is constant
distance dx you hope that it will be
much larger than constant
okay so why should we care about quantum
coding um
well the main reason and probably the
reason we are earlier today is that
yeah i mean
the reason that the feed of quantum
computation exists
is because of the threshold theorem it
tells you that
if you want to you know perform
some logical circuit
and some qubits with you know mq bits t
gates
and if you don't have access to an ideal
you know setting where everything is
perfect but
and constantly everything is kind of
noisy and you have a physical error rate
where i get which is p
then you can still you can still
simulate the you know the behavior of
your perfect circuit
if you use a photogram circuit which is
slightly larger than the the idler
circuit that you want to that you want
to simulate
and this is possible provided that the
their rate is below some threshold okay
say one percent
but the cost for doing this is that the
number of bits of qb that you need is
not m anymore it's m times some
pre-logarithmic factor
m and t the number of gates
so this is very well and the strategy to
prove this theorem is to use
concatenation
so the idea is that okay you want to
perform some computation with qubits so
the error quality is p so what you do
every of your every qubit you will
encode it with this kind of code with
the steam code so every qubit is encoded
into seven physical qubits
uh so my qubit is encoded in seven
critical qubits when you do that because
the steam code has distance three you
can correct one error
and so the effective you know physical
write goes from p to roughly p squared
okay and if p squared is still too large
what you can do you can you can do it
again so
every one of your seven new qubits that
you have developed you anchored them
once again
with the same steam code and now you
have 49 qubits per logical cubit and
when you do that the rate goes to p to
the fourth and if you do l levels like
this
and the red drops to p to the 2 to the l
and if you want to achieve some target
you know
noise level which is roughly you know if
you have t gates and m qubits
it's enough to have like an effective
error rate that is below 1 over mt
then if you want to reach this level you
can just use log log 1 rpm levels
and then the number of qubits that you
need to do that
scales like m times you know polylog
1 over epsilon so this is how you get a
pretty look really quick overhead
for this special crm
okay so this is
this is good start
but when i started my phd like 15 years
ago i went to my first conference it was
qapc in barcelona
at that time i was working on something
completely different i was working on
you know classical cryptography
[Music]
but then i saw the talk of david pooler
and analyst stuck with me
and david was saying you know this good
concatenation that we use for the
threshold theorem is from a coding point
of view is terribly suboptimal you know
the rate of this of this classical code
that you use is terrible it's really bad
so why not why not use you know better
codes with constant height
like quantum dpc codes to do full
tolerance quantum computing
so i don't recall exactly all the
details of this talk that it stokes
but but okay i can reconstruct a little
bit so why do you need you know constant
height if you have constant rate and
code instead of this concatenated scheme
um then you know you encode k logical
qubits into you know n physical cubits
and nnk they are just quality they
constant then you can hope to remove
this pretty logarithmic factor in the
right
and so that's the easy part then the
tricky part is that you know you need
the reason there is a code is because
you want to correct errors in your
computation so you want to be able you
know to measure the syndrome at every
time at each time step and to correct
the errors as as they come
and you hope to to correct your athletes
faster or not more slowly than
than they can
okay so you need like a good syndrome
extraction procedure
and the syndrome extraction procedure it
will be faulty as well it will be noisy
so if you want to be able to you know
extract the syndrome in such a way the
synonym is not too noisy
you want like a
circuit to do this syndrome genome
expression that is constant depth
and if you want to do that and you know
there's a there's a scheme proposed by
peter shaw to do that
but it only works
if the checks of the of the code they
are
you know they have constant weight
so this is why we need a quarterback dpc
code if we want to apply this kind of
ideas we want to quantum elliptic code
with constant height
okay and then we can hope maybe um to do
um quantum field tolerance with constant
overrides
okay so what are contaminated codes so i
i mentioned the definition before but
okay let's let's try to look at an
example so
i record that what we want we want
commuting
x checks and z checks
uh of constant weight okay concentrate
is for ldpc and we want the quantum code
so we want committing x checks and the
checks
if you try to figure out the code that
will do that and you want to do that by
hand
you will get into a lot of trouble
because it's not easy to do that
some of these two these two you know
constraints that they don't go well with
each other
and one brilliant insight of ptaf at the
end of 90s was to say okay there's a
there's one place mathematics where this
kind of
these two things they kind of occur
naturally and this is in topology
and since then i mean topology has been
very useful for designing quantum codes
and so the idea of kitaya for us to say
okay let's take a manifold so for
instance the torus
and then you you put the tiling on the
choice okay so you put the tiling on the
toilets and what you will do you will
put the edge the queue bits
and the edges
of the styling
and then the z checks and the x checks
you will define them like this so you
you will have two types of checks
you will have x checks so this will be
star operators so for each vertex
you will
you will define an x check and this is
just
the operator that applies a pulley x
on each of the four
you know edges
incident to a vertex so you just use
that everywhere in the choice
and you define the z checks
for each placket so for each blackhead
you take the product of all the z
operators around the placket
okay and if you do that you can observe
that these two types of paradigms they
commute so either
you know their support it doesn't
overlap don't overlap then they you know
they commute
trivially
but then
when they overlap so say that you take
the
x check corresponding to this vertex
then the support they will overlap twice
so one for this edge and one for that
edge
and so you can check that you have the
communication relation that you want
and so you get a quantum lgbt code and
you know with checks of wait for
and this code is not bad um
so it encodes you know n qubits the
number of edges in your in your tiling
so that's right the number of physical
qubits is n the number of logical qubits
is two it doesn't so good but okay you
are good sensing and the distance of the
code is not too bad you square with m
okay and today this is somehow the
leading approach to do you know 43 on
what i'm computing so not with the toy
code but with a surface got
a 2d version
like a planar version of the of the toy
code
but besides your besides application for
you know photo layouts
this kind of causes the
i mean they
have played quite
an interesting role you know in in
physics
because they kind of give you new phases
of matter
uh for instance i mean uh
the quotation difficult it's nothing but
the degenerate ground space of some
committing poli-local hamiltonian okay
and so you'll be submitting which is
local and
and then you can look at the crown space
and it will you know display
new properties like topological
entanglement
and so on
but but really the the point that is
important for this talk is that
this thing this story called the surface
code which is the closed cousin um this
is a leading approach to many you know
attempts to do photo around quantum
computing
and okay what i would like to advertise
in this talk is
okay so i stole this from from scratch
well known you know quantum pcp
manifesto and i want to advertise the
quantum ldpc manifesto
okay so
the observation is that you know this
code the surface code has been invented
25 years ago and in the last 25 years
people have devised you know photoleon
techniques
they have developed these techniques to
to use these codes you know with these
codes in mind with surface codes
radicals and other variants but these
codes are not so good
and this leads to massive overrides okay
for fault tolerance so if you want to
you know run insurance algorithms factor
non-trigger numbers and break an essay
or something
um the number of physical qubits that
you need per logical qubits is maybe
one thousand ten thousand so it's
this is a huge cost
and somehow the the approach i would
like to advertise uh
is to say okay maybe what we should do
is to find good quantum led codes first
and then try to use them into photoeleme
to do further on quantum computing
instead of using the bad codes that we
had before i mean bad in the coding
theory sense
um
so let's try to to yeah
find good quaternary secrets first and
then
and then exploit those
and probably along the way we'll get
also new interesting results like new
exotic phrases of matter unexpected
consequences in complexity theory and so
on
okay so okay so what do we want we want
some good ldpc codes so this is what i
will talk about in the rest of the talk
um
we want efficient decoding so we are not
there yet and we want also something
that completely omitted for now is the
ability you know to perform logical
gates with these goals
and for this question i mean much more
work is needed so i won't talk about
that today
okay so can we get better quantum
medicine than the toy code
um so yeah in the past 20 years people
one you know one avenue that has been
very fruitful to design new cotton codes
is the topological approach okay so the
toy code construction is is beautiful
and you can generalize it in number of
ways so you can take any mini food that
you want not a tourist but anything that
you want you can work in any dimension
that you want you can work in euclidean
space you can work in
hyperbolic space
you can generalize this approach to get
you know a flurry of different quote
unquote family
and these
but somehow all these codes
constructions they they suffer from very
strong limitations
particular one one result with the
important reason from bravi poular and
barbara
from 2009 is that this goes if you look
at their parameters k d and n
and k and d cannot be arbitrarily large
okay in particular if you look at two
dimensional codes topological codes like
the surface code
the toy code
you have the constraint that k times d
squared
should be uh order n okay so if you
and the toy code kind of uh you know
satisfies this so take code you have k
equals constant and this quote and
again you can generate these results to
say that good cause they will require a
lot of you know long-range interactions
okay so the kind of the lesson if you
want to get better codes is that you
okay you can keep sparsity you can keep
the idea that you want a sparse party
check matrix but you should drop this
you know this constraint of having
geometric locality in d dimensions
so that's one lesson and the other thing
that i want to stress is that you know
in the classical case
getting a good
just proving the existence of good
ellipsis is trivial you just take a
random strategic matrix and you can
protect it it's good with high
probabilities and the quantum case if
you do something purely wrong a purely
random construction it won't work
and the reason is as follows if you take
so we have two matrices to take hx and
hz
so if you take hx to be random
then with high probability just because
of the of the classical case the
distance of the
classical code corresponding to hx will
be large will be linear n with high
probability
but you know you have this
commutation relation that you want and
this computational relation says that
the you know the support of the
of the z checks they should be code
words of cx
and
and so you cannot it cannot be the case
so if this is true
with this hz which is stars
then it's not possible that hx has
distance order of n the distance of h x
of c x should be order one
so if you take a purely random
construction it won't work so you need a
little bit of structure
but it's very hard you know to to take
the right amount of structure if you
take a bit too much
than what was done for the topological
constructions then you get too much
structure somehow and you you get this
you know the super bounce so you cannot
get good ldbc so you really want to find
the minimal amount of structure that you
need to
to ensure commutativity but at the same
time to
to keep you know a good distance and a
good good rate
okay so this is and yeah this has been a
very
complicated problem for the past 20
years
okay so
yeah in the beginning of the talk i want
to to explain to you how to do that so
yeah how to get good quality pc codes so
k and d both linear in n
so it's a story in two acts so the first
act is to boost you know the dimension
and the second act would be to boost the
distance which is harder to do
okay so
how to boost the dimension so
again it was like a beautiful insight
from tillich and zimmer in 2009
what they observed is that
the torus
you can see it as a product of two
cycles okay the red cycle and you know
the blue cycle if you have the blue
cycle going around the right cycle then
it will
it will draw a torus
um
and then if you have a cycle like this
or if you look at the classical code
with stylographs so the graphs that i
had before correspond to a cycle it's
just it's just a repetition code okay so
in some sense
in some well-defined sense the toy code
is nothing but the product of two
classical repetition codes okay so if
you have two repetition codes for
addition code has length and you know it
encodes one bit so you have two words
either everything is zero everything is
one
and the distance is n because you have
two words and
they have maximum distance you need to
keep all the bits to go from the all
zero world to the old one world so
you know the parameters of the
observation codes are n and n so if you
take the product of two repetition code
you get you know the toric code
and then what what this and zemer you
know asked is whether you could somehow
generalize this to
to products of arbitrary classical codes
not just the repetition code but you
take two arbitrary codes and you would
get a quote on code and it turns out
that you can do that and this is exactly
what they did back then
so if you take two arbitrary classical
codes with parameters you know nkd and
kd
then you get a quantum code
uh of length
roughly n squared that encodes roughly k
squared cubits
and that has distance d if your distance
d squared then this would be wonderful
you would get
you know good ellipsis codes
because i mean if you take two classical
digitals you get the quantum energy
cause um
but unfortunately the distance you know
it's not squared is just
basically the minimum of the two
classical distances
but still i mean if you take the product
of two good ldpc codes you get a quantum
ldpc code
with constant rate
okay and minimum distance square root n
so basically you get a huge improvement
compared to the toy code
you keep the same scaling for the
distance
but the dimension it goes from constant
to linear in m okay
so that's uh
it's very interesting and this
construction is a very special case of
the homological product construction of
pravi and essence
so you manage to generalize this to you
know you can take products of quantum
codes and you will get another quantum
codes
okay so this is already quite good and
also the this is i mean
it's even better than expected because
uh thanks to a result of danielle
coutusman
published in 2013. so danielle had the
colloquium about this last year so what
danielle did in this paper is to show
you know how to use this
almost good quadrant ldpc codes to
to perform
full tolerance quantum computing
with constant over it instead of pulling
over it
and
in this recipe you need two ingredients
so in two things
uh you need
reasonably good
quotable dips in contaminate
so the dimension you know our vertical
qubit should scale linearly with n
and you want the distance to be not too
bad okay but you don't want you don't
need it to be linear in n it's
sufficient if the distance goes you know
polynomially with n
with any you know exponent which is
above zero
so this is kind of easy to do i mean
[Music]
the
construction just gives you that
and what is what is also needed in
daniel um
strategy is you need a very good decoder
uh for this code
and that will you know collect uh errors
very well and
the very hard part to get is you need
like a very efficient decoder you need
the decoder to work to work in constant
depth because the idea i mean if you
recall the way you do you would do the
computation is at each time step between
you know a logical case
you would measure the syndrome then you
feed the syndrome to a classical decoder
then the classical decoder tries to
guess what is the most likely error and
then you correct for the error and then
you continue with your computation
but the point is that during the
time and where your classical decoding
algorithm tries to
compute the most likely era from the
syndrome during that time the you know
the noise t accumulates so if the time
is too long then the noise will
accumulate too much and you won't be
able to correct anything so it's very
crucial to have
a very fast
classical decoder for this code
and what we did a few years ago is to
show that
you know if you take the hypergraph
project code of two classical exponent
codes
and if you use a special decoding
algorithm you could spread the trip and
then you have
these two ingredients and then you can
apply you know
daniel
the recipe to to get quote-unquote
tolerance with constant overhead
so in some sense this gives already a
positive answer to david pollan's vision
which was so okay let's use you know
quota dipsy code with concentrates to
get
constant overhead
computing
okay but in some sense we are still not
very happy i mean it's still a bit
frustrating that this course are not as
good as my on my trip okay so the big
question is can we get even better
quantum leap sequence can we can we get
the distance to be much larger than
square root n
uh and if we can maybe this will lead to
much better thresholds you know fewer
assumptions on the noise model that you
need to have these fault tolerance
schemes to work and so on so
okay so let's try to do that so
before i explain to you how we can beat
this down let me explain
why we were stuck for many years at this
don't
um
so the this hyper product construction
that i that i mentioned i didn't explain
it in detail but uh the way it works is
as follows so you take two classical
codes
c a and c b so we have n bits and the n
minus k in operating
and this hypergraph product construction
it just takes this these two classical
codes and turn them into
you know quantum code
and the quantum code will look like this
so you have two sets of qubits like this
[Music]
square
and by n
set of two bits here you have an n minus
k times n minus k set of q bits
then you have a bunch of x checks and a
bunch of z checks
i won't explain in detail how it works
but the
kind of the idea is that
all the columns here in the right there
are several copies of this classical
code ca
and all the the blue rows
that you have everywhere there are
copies of of cb so here you have your
nbs if you want and you have your minus
k
and parity checks
okay so the quantum code is hyperlapse
code
it really consists of many copies of the
classical codes that you started with
and
what is not so good is that if you take
a good word of the classical code of ca
that's a bunch of bits that will satisfy
all the equations
then this code word gives you a logical
operator of the quantum code if you just
put the same code word
in this column if you put a codeword of
cb in this row this will give you you
know logical operators
and because of that the distance of the
quantum code cannot be cannot exceed the
length of the of the row here or the
column here
and if you optimize the two distances
should be equal
so you end up
with a distance which scales like square
root of the number of qubits okay the
distance is really the length of this
row and the number of physical qubits is
the you know is the number of rows times
the number of grams okay so this is and
all the construction that we knew before
they were
you know
they were following this kind of pattern
and we were really stuck with this
square root and bound for the distance
okay so how can we beat this because we
can now yeah we didn't know that two
years ago but now we know
okay so before i tell you that let me
just quickly recap the you know the
history of quota elliptic code with
large minimum distance so i already
mentioned topological costs so in n7 ktf
you know it divides this sorry code that
gives the distance squared n
then a few years later mayor friedman
mayor and leo they
use much more complicated manifold
instead of the torus and that you know
improves the distance a bit but it's
really a little bit you know just by a
factor
log n to the one force
okay
and then for 20 years
nothing happened um
but somehow in the past few years i mean
in classical coding theory and classical
complexity theory people started to to
explore new kind of objects you know
either natural generalization of graphs
external graphs um
and somehow this this kind of new object
they they give rise to interesting
quantum codes um
[Music]
and in 2012
i mean there were two papers using this
kind of ideas to improve a little bit on
the bond and the distance but you know
not by much first square with n times
log n then squaring
n times log n to
to any constant
but still we are stuck at this square
with n
at this point um
square root n bond
and then really the breakthrough
occurred just one month later so
first in the brilliant paper by uh
essence iron ordinal so it was really
the first paper that
that broke
the square root n bond
with this fiber bundle construction so
they managed to get the distance
and to the 0.6
and then a few months later there was
like a
an explicit construction of this code
and a conjecture
by reichmann and nebert
this balanced product codes that could
give potentially you know good quality
obstacles
and again in december of that year in
2020 panteleif and kyle chef they
managed to do the device they invented
lifted product codes
where the distance is almost linearized
n divided by log n
which is really really good
but at that time the the dimension was
not so good so k was just logarithmic in
n instead of you know linear and n
so this was like one year ago and then
probably you heard this a few months ago
november so listen to
colleagues some colleagues
they managed to finally you know achieve
the grail
of cotton coding so to prove the
existence of
asymptotically good quantum ellipse
equals
and
sort of unexpectedly
this construction it also gave
a construction for a different object
that is interesting in the classical
complexity theory which is our classical
coding theory it's called
a classical locally testable codes
and on the same day that this paper
appeared there was another paper
devising you know this kind of locally
disabled codes
so there was a talk by dino last year
and
you know a series of the
assignments
so you can watch this talk if you want
um and the reason i mentioned these two
things is because i mean you know
the first paper the the code of dipsy
paper
as a by-product of the quantum ellipse
construction they gave also
a solution construction of locally
disabled codes
and turns out that this kind of two
objects are very connected and
now we have a few more examples so an
example that we'll talk about
uh in construction uh by myself and jill
zimmer we
also give a construction for quantum
medicine that gives
also classical locally testable code
exactly the same
as in the generator paper
and so now the set of effects is this
you you have these two kind of objects
classical ltc's and the quantum ellipse
codes and turns out that every time we
have a quantum egyptic code it gives
also classical
locally testable code
so we have two constructions of quantum
mechan codes
and or two and a half
and we have three construction of
classical
ltc's and two and a half because you
have
been recently a paper by lean and shea
where they
give a construction of classical ltc
uh and you give only a conditional you
know construction of quantum mechanics
called
its condition and
verifying a conjecture for some objects
exist
[Music]
okay so how do we write oh i'll do these
papers and achieve to break the square
with n barrier
um so here is kind of the intuition
so if you recall the
hypothetical product code that's great
before
so
um
just look at the top slice of the
picture
and it was what we had before so we had
like many classical codes many copies of
the classical code
the red copies and the blue copies
and somehow
you know if you have a word of the
classical code in this in this
on this copy it gives you a logical
operator of the quantum of the quantum
code
so the idea to to to break this square
with n bond is to somehow add a third
dimension
uh and to
picture it what you would like to have
is something like this so you would like
to have
you know many copies of a classical code
but now the classical code did
correspond to a slice so either a red
slice or a blue slice
um and the hope now that is that you
know um because these slabs this size
they share a lot of
you know degrees of freedom all these
vertical coordinates
the hope is that you know classical
world
of the the red code will be something
that you know
has weight like linear in the size of
the of the slice
and now because the the weight of the of
the slice compared to the total weight
total size of the quantum code which is
this cube
is much larger than before it's just you
know you have only delta slices like
this so you could have up to get a
distance that scales like
you know the the
the length of this the height of this uh
this cube so n by delta squared
times delta so you could hope to really
improve the distance in this way
and this is exactly what happens for the
quantum tenor cuts that i will explain
in a minute or two
but so to do that
yeah we need
we need more structure that we had than
we had before so before you know with
this hyper product cut cross section you
could take two arbitrary classical codes
and they would always give you a quantum
code now somehow you need some structure
because you you need
the two codes the blue code and the red
code to to share you know all these uh
vertical
degrees of freedom if you want so you
cannot take arbitrary codes
so you need more structure
and all the papers i mentioned i
mentioned that beat the square root and
bound
they all use you know different
terminology but somehow
you know
you know
behind the curtain it's always kind of
the same topological if you want um a
tool that you use
and it's probably this balanced product
[Music]
construction of pointline or
neighborhood art so in some sense you
could say that all these all these
examples there are specific examples of
this um finance project consulting
okay so okay so i won't i won't explain
these these three codes because now they
are a bit complicated i will try to
focus on this one which hopefully is the
the simplest one to understand
so quantum 10 occurs
but before i do that let me just you
know quickly go through the classical
case because you know clericals have
been invented for classical coding they
were invented by tanner and 81
and the idea behind this code is to you
know
build a large code from a delta regular
graph so we have a graph of degree delta
and you have small codes of length delta
and the idea is to put the bits on the
edges of the graph okay so you put the
bits on the edges of the graph
and you put the constraints
on the you know on the on the vertices
and the way you put the constraints is
by asking
the local view here this uh this vertex
so the
vertex it views number
of bits a number of edges um you will
ask that this this
restriction of the code world to this
you know here four
or five
um
bits this has to belong to some small
quotes okay so that's the idea between
behind and then our codes so the first
example of you know 10 our code is
product codes also known as tensor codes
so in that case the graph that you take
is just a you know complete bipartite
graph
so you have n bits on one side and this
on the other side oh sorry and vertices
on one side and vertices on the other
side
and you have n squared
edges so n squared bits
and you have two types of local views
you have the local views from the a side
on the left side and you have the local
views from the b side
and the way it works is that some of the
a side on the
it gives you a partition of the so here
the square is supposed to represent all
the edges
okay so the edges they are somehow you
know labeled by a times b so you start
from any vertex a and then you have
b choices to
to define the
um your edge
um
so the edge set is isomorphic to eight
times b um and the the product code is
just this is just you ask that if you
look at the restriction
of the code word on every column it
should be a good word of c a or some
classical code ca and if you look at the
resolution on any row it should be a
code word of some you know critical
called cb
so this is the product construction
another construction that was
you know
very important in the field of quantum
media coding
is the expander code construction here
the idea is to take okay
the next best thing after the complete
bipartite graph you take an exponent
graph so somewhere
i won't explain what exponent traps are
but
it's just like some
a sparse graph that behaves so more like
a
complete bipartite graph
and one way to define this graph is as
follows you can just you know you take a
group
g
and your vertices there will be two
copies of the group g
and then you take a subset
of g
subset a
and then so the vertices there are
elements of the groups
and then you put an edge between two
vertices g and a g if you go from g to a
g by multiplying g by a
an element of the set a
okay and so you do that everywhere
um
if you take the subset a to be of size
delta
and your graph to be excited delta then
you can enforce you know local
constraints you will ask that you know
each local view here
is a good word of some small code
c0
and if you take a good small code and if
you have an expanded graph and you get a
good
you know expander code with you know
efficient decoding algorithms
but some of the important part here is
that
this
when you look at this you have two types
of views you know you have the views
from the left the blue ones you have the
the red views from the right and these
two types of views they give you two
partitions of the set of edges okay so
this is some of the set of edges g times
a so you take you start from any point
every any other text in here and you can
for any vertex you have a possibilities
to define an edge
so these two types of local views that
define two partitions of your set of
edges of your setup bits
okay and so in the quantum quantum
construction for the quad antenna code
what we want to do is to take you know
we we need two classical codes cx and cz
um
and what we will do is we will take
these two codes to be both classical
10 of codes
but somehow to do that we need four
partitions of the qubits
and i recall that we need this
commutation constraint this is the the
hardest thing to get
um
and so to get the commutation constraint
you cannot take a graph like this
because if you take a graph and you
enforce constraints so say x checks on
the left on the blue sticks set checks
on the right on the right things
then x and z they will either not
overlap or they will overlap once but if
the overall approach they won't commute
they will anticommit so
this won't give you a way to get to
quantum codes
so the idea to get a qualm code is to go
and you know to move to something a bit
higher dimensional than a graph and to
move to a modular complex where you and
we will replace the edges we won't put
the
qubits on the edges but we will put the
qubits on you know
squares
okay and so the tool to do that is
really the left height kelly complex
that was defined by dino atar
so in the quantum construction what we
need now we need four so we need a group
as before g
but now we take four copies of
g and then we need two subsets a and b
okay of g so a and b are both of size
delta they are both of constant size
and now we have two types of edges
we have blue edges so types type a so g
will be connected to a g
between these two sets of
vertices
here some gb will be connected to a
times gb
and we have no red edges that correspond
to the set p
where g is connected to g b
so it's important that i mean it's
called left-hand complex
because when you move with a you a acts
on the left of the the group element
and when we you use a you know a b type
edge uh
b
acts on the right
okay and when you have this uh what type
so you have these edges but what you
have
now in addition is you have mini squares
so a square is just this thing that i
represented here so you have g you can
go to a times g
and then if you make a b
you know b step you go to a g b
but you can go either way
to 8gb if you go first through gb and
then to 8gb
okay so this uh
this thing has a lot of squares like
this and the number of squares is you
know the squares
they are labeled by g times a time b you
have element
group elements here and then you have to
choose an element of a and element of b
each local view so for each vertex at
each vertex you see delta squared
squares
so the local views are isomorphic to a
times b and you have four types of views
so before you have two types of views
because you know in the
graph case you have an edge that can
belong you know to belongs to
its incident two vertices
and now you have a square and it's
incident to four vertices so we have
four types of views
um
and what we want to do is you know we
want to we want to define two types of
constraints of checks
um x checks and z checks um so we have
you know red local views for these two
types of
vertices in blue local views for these
two types of vertices
and if i you know this is the set of all
the squares
um
so we have four types of vertices of
views
which are rule of size a times b
and
really the crucial point is that when
you have two local views so a blue and a
red local view they will always share
either a column narrow okay or nothing
but say this one and this one you know
if you you make them develop they will
share this kind of
this kind of raw or column and this one
and this one you know they will share
this this whole column
so the way you can get
you know a quantum code
um
so now you have
the the you know the
the checks they can overlap on a large
number of
qubits
and the way to get a codon code the way
to get the commutation is by putting
checks
that correspond to transfer product
codes
code words
with two types of codes c and cb and the
dual of c and cd okay so for instance
here you have x checks you have z checks
and if you take the blue view that will
you know that will overlap
with this red view on this on this this
column
for the red
check it will be a good word of ca for
the blue view it will be a code word of
c a pair so they will be orthogonal so
they will commute so this is the way you
enforce communication with this kind of
[Music]
f complex
okay so
so the quantum telecoms there are this
so you you get an explicit construction
you use a generical left side kelly
complex
in their paper they give an explicit
construction of how to get that
to get quantum phenol codes you can just
pick the small code c and cp to be a
random goods
and then you get a quantum ldpc code
with you know constant threat um
which is positive
and the main result is that you know
if
if these things so if these two codes so
these two goes c a times cb perp and c a
perp times c perps
these two cones they are the dual of you
know product codes
um
so if these two codes they are robust
and i will explain what this means
and then then you can show that the the
distance of the quantum telecoil uh is
linear in n
and the bound is essentially tight and
this is exactly what happens
with this fight before the
the logical operators they will be in a
single slice
as i showed before
so this robustness it will hold with a
high probability for a nation which is
positive
and as a corollary of this result we
have the we obtain exactly the locality
stability of the
locally testable code of kinematal
so i don't know how much time i have um
left
it's it's okay it can take a few more
minutes okay
just to quickly explain the idea behind
the proof
of the distance of this code
so i mean the strategy process is kind
of always the same so
you say you start with a logical
operator or a logical world
of small size so below the distance and
what you can do is you you show that
so you have a word of cx
and then you show that if this word
has weight which is too small then you
can decrease this weight by just adding
a generator of the code
and then you can repeat this and you
will decrease the weight until you get
to zero
and in this way you prove that that x
this word is called one of cx was in
fact the sum of generators so it does
not count for the mean distance so the
minimum distance has to be larger than
this
and the way you prove that um okay so
let's say that we we look at the x-type
you know error so it should satisfy
if it's not if it's in the in cx it
should satisfy you know all the blue
constraints
and the blue constraint they ask you
that
you know the constraint the checks the
checks are the element of ca perhaps
that is cb perp so if you satisfy the
check you commit with a check means that
the local view belongs to the dual of
this tensor code
and the drill of a tensor code is a
interesting code it's just
you know uh so a tensor code would be
every row and every line
is an element of the code of the small
quotes
the dual tensor code is a bit different
it's uh the local view is the sum
of some columns and some of those
which are either in c or in cd
and so x any code word that you have
it's a it's actually a good word a
classical tenor code defined on the
delta squared regular exponent graph
but with bad local codes because the
local codes that you use are really dual
and tensor codes and these dual tone
circles they have a pro distance
distance delta instead of delta squares
um and the location stable could of
generated is exactly the same and said
that that you you take the
for the for the small codes you take the
the tensor cos c a times c and this
one's at large distance
so in our case x is a good word of a bad
classical telecoin but this is necessary
because we know that you know the
classical
cx must contain you know the set checks
so it's gonna be a good code
so if you want to analyze what happens
you really need to exploit the structure
of this gelatin circles um and this was
done in the paper by pendleton khf
and they showed that for this dwell
tensor code
you have a very special property which
is
you know if you have an element so
a code word is your system of columns
and rows
if you have a sum which has low weight
say lower than this
then you can always write it as a sum of
a very small number of rows and columns
okay in some sense you cannot have too
much
cancellations between
rows and columns if the final weight is
small
so that's the crucial property that we
need
and then the proof is not that
complicated so
so you have a word
which is
this you know a word of this um
classical tenor code so in each blue
view
um using expansion in
the graph you can show that you know the
the local degree is not too large it's
order of delta and the size of the view
is delta squared
so because of that you can use
robustness of the translucent code to
say okay this view technology
corresponds to a sum of a constant
number of rows and columns in each of
these local views
so in particular for each of these local
views
the columns and the rows they don't
perturb
themselves okay the rows won't perform
much the columns and vice versa because
you know you have only like a constant
number of rows and columns
so it means that in this local views
everywhere when column is very close to
a code word of ca or cv
and then you can use expansion
properties of the
uh the click complex to show that all
these you know non-zero code words all
these non-zero rows they have to
agglutinate some of the red local views
and the other type of local views
and so in this other type of local views
because of what we said before each all
the rows and all the columns they must
be very close to codewords of the
smaller codes
and then you can use you know the
robustness of some circles this is
something that is well
known
classical coding to show that
there has to exist one at least one red
local view where
you know the local view is very close to
a code word of ca times cb and this is
nothing but like a check a generator so
you can you know you can flip this
generator and then this will decrease
the weight
of x and you can repeat this and you get
to zero and so this proves that x
is the sum of you know um
of uh of of checks of generators
this proves the lower abundant distance
okay so that concludes what i wanted to
say so
to summarize so
i mean for 20 years
nothing much happened and
you know in quantum ellipse code in the
coding theory
we were stuck at distance of order
square root n
and then in the past 20 18 months uh i
mean there's been
tremendous progress and now uh thanks to
this result by patellar and khf we know
that good quantum ellipsis exists
and we have even simplified construction
of this um another the big question is
okay can we use that to do something
interesting for photographs what i'm
computing
i mean it has to be the case that this
codes they have to be good to put on
photo around quantum computing
so this opens like a
flurry of new open questions you can
find better good ellipsis code
with episode decoder small size
something so that i could be ignored in
this talk is how to perform uh logical
gates on these general musicals so there
are papers that
that start to appear on these questions
and of course something that i
completely ignored is okay the
how do you implement these things okay
so this is a challenge for
experimentalists so you really need to
implement these things
and so this means that you need you know
qubits that can interact and and you
need long range interaction to
to make these codes possible
so that's a huge challenge of course
okay and that concludes what i want you
to say so thanks for your attention
great um
thanks very much for giving us such a
great uh panorama
of this field and also
of uh catching us up on the recent work
that's fantastic talk anthony thanks a
lot
so um
so there are a lot of um
actually experts on this on this
on the subject in the audience and also
on the panel
so
let's see are there any are there any
questions before we move on to the panel
um
perhaps we can we can
we can roll in questions also with the
panel itself um since we are since we
are
running a little bit low on time so uh
let's let's go ahead and uh if you can
stop sharing your your slides anthony
then
you can
get the
panelists videos pinned
um so um so we have a
a really um fantastic panel um
um
of um
of um
you know which which has um let me
introduce the panelists so barbara
terhar who's at the
uh dealt uh university of technology she
um she's worked
for a very long time on um you know on
quantum on all aspects of quantum
information but uh but the one thing
that
that she
you know her work has focused on
particularly uh which is important for
for this this particular panel is on uh
both quantum era correction and fault
tolerance
and so uh great to have you here uh
barbara um thank you
yeah and uh
there's also danny
daniel gottesman who
again he's a physicist by training but
he just
he just moved to uh university of
maryland where he's
where he uh
he has a professorship in the computer
science department so he really crosses
between the two
and of course he he's worked on
you know
uh
various aspects of uh
quantum correction fault tolerance
including uh
you know including uh
introducing the notion of stabilizer
codes
and uh
our third panelist is matt hastings uh
at microsoft who's um
again you know
everybody on this panel has had this
you know extremely wide view so
uh matt is uh you know he's
he's done
i guess as much as anybody else to
to uh to create this field of quantum
hamiltonian complexity and of course he
had
he had a
big role to play in the story that
anthony told us
so um you know it would be great to hear
each of your views about about this
whole subject i guess there are there
are many things to
to
to talk about including things that
anthony
said about um you know how close you
know how far are we along this road with
uh
um quantum ldpc codes in terms of
parameters in terms of efficient
decoding
uh there's also issues about fault
tolerance uh you know how do you
when when you're working with these
large codes uh how to do your operations
due to them uh do you do single bit
operations at a time or can you actually
paralyze them
there's also the complexity theory
aspects of this you know are there are
what are the implications of of this
work for
the nlts conjecture or for are they
going to be you know
what what's you know
or
quantum ltc um
and then there's of course uh physical
uh
implications you know uh you know uh
anthony spoke about
well uh
you know how kitayas uh uh code you know
introduced a new phase of matter so
is you know are there physics
implications of all these quotes so i'll
just turn it over to each of you and see
what you have to say so
would you like to say something barbara
and
okay i'll say something
uh yeah of course i think it's fantastic
of course that uh there's such a
breakthrough
uh
and that we understand this a lot better
now
and i think there probably will be
further consolation consolidation
of these codes and these various
constructions to
to understand it
um
i mean i i think for myself i i have
always felt that maybe for practical
purposes
which are not necessarily mathematically
so interesting it's threshold that
counts a lot
right
at this stage of development
and as far maybe maybe anthony can
comment on this or somebody else that
i think this is a bit open
whether these codes are going to be very
good in that respect and then the other
thing is as anthony said the embedding
and
so
i'm sure they'll find some place in in
quantum computing but where exactly and
at what time to me that that's still a
bit open
um
yeah so that's one comment i'd like to
make
i don't know if anybody can respond i
guess people can respond or other people
on this whole panel can they respond or
this is yes absolutely yeah okay yeah
um yeah can i can i make a comment um
i you know i agree with barbara that we
don't know where these will fit in i
kind of have the feeling now when it
comes to quantum coding
that you know since
there are no qubits out there that are
below threshold for any codes
essentially at the moment we should be
investigating everything when it comes
to quantum codes and
who knows what will prove useful and
perhaps certain codes will prove more
useful for certain platforms i mean some
platforms may be constrained more for
geometric locality maybe these codes
won't be useful for those platforms
maybe these codes will be useful though
for communicating between you know
different devices maybe you'll have
something built on a you know on a
two-dimensional surface you'll be
constrained to that code but maybe
they'll communicate with some other
quantum device and these codes will be
useful so i think practically like we
need to investigate everything um i mean
you know it's familiar from standard
classical error correction that you use
different codes for different
communication channels so i think right
now until we have an actual physical
device we should be doing everything
yeah i think that that i mean that's
very good point i was actually wondering
whether you have
you know you've also worked on flokay
codes mats and whether you have uh would
there be a quantum ldpc version of the
4k code because that sounds like
i i don't know i don't know
you know i've been trying to wonder if
like you know can these flowca codes be
interpreted in some more standard
homological formulation which makes it
clear i i don't know you know it's
definitely like an interesting um an
interesting open question to try to
investigate that um
and uh
you know i just i just want to add
something else um i don't want to derail
too much like there's the practical
interest
um but then i think these are really
fascinating mathematically for a lot of
reasons like it's a fundamental thing in
coding theory um it's a fundamental
thing in quantum
complexity theory you know it may
let you prove
things that might lead to a quantum pcp
theorem
and um
uh you know i'll just if i can advertise
a piece of my own work with uh mike
freeman and i we had a you know a lot of
the early codes like the kataya code the
torque code and then friedman wire luo
came from uh
starting with something in topology some
manifold and topology like a taurus or
friedman meyer lua was a much more
complicated man of felt as anthony said
and then building a code from that so
mike friedman and i kind of came up with
the construction to take
one of these codes and turn it back into
a manifold so that the torque code on
that manifold has these large distance
properties and so on um not a
two-dimensional amount manifold on much
higher dimensional manifold and it leads
to some interesting constructions in
geometry so i think like from the point
of view of math these codes are just
incredibly interesting too
um
sorry so can you can you say a little
bit um a little bit more about um
you know
uh
what what this you know
uh
you know what this potential path
towards quantum pcp might look like if
you know what does this open up in terms
of uh
in terms of getting that
well i mean i mean we would want i guess
the the nicest first thing would be to
get like this nlts conjecture which is
that um
there's some
hamiltonian where
no low energy state is related to the
product state by a circuit um
that's that's a requirement for quantum
pcp and and you might hope that these
these codes something like these codes
might have these properties um
um
you know
i guess in one sense like they lead to
quant they lead to classical locally
testable codes and maybe some version of
them could lead to a quantum locally
testable code um you know it just seems
like the next big breakthrough in
encoding theory like like you know
three years ago like i could not dream
that someone would write down a linear
distance code and now
this is done like
the two big breakthroughs clearly are
now making it efficiently decodable and
i think
making a locally testable quantum code
just
i don't know how to do it if i know how
to do it maybe
but it just seems so exciting that like
how can this be yeah how can you how can
that
how can they have written down such a
good code
yeah
so um yeah i certainly want to second uh
uh everything that that matt and barbara
have said i mean i i agree that finding
kind of practical protocols using these
ldpc codes is a
it's a pretty uh important uh open
problem still
um let me add another one that i think
is not really on people's radars that i
think might might also follow from from
this result which is
another long-standing open question of
the quantum channel capacity
um even the quantum channel custody of
the depolarizing channel
um so that's uh you know very simple
channel
and yet we know
that you can do slightly better
very slightly better
um for the for the channel capacity of
the polarizing channel than you could
with a random code
and the reason for that is that you can
have codes where errors collide where
they do the same thing
and so they kind of fill up less space
in the hilbert space and you can fit
more code words in
um and we only know how to do this by
very very little bit
um and but maybe it's possible to do a
lot better because the upper bounds are
nowhere near what we can do right now
and um
the way to do that would be to have
codes where there's a lot of errors
colliding and what that means is that
the code would be an ldpc code
um and uh it
doesn't necessarily have to be a good
lgbc code because the difference between
you know typical errors and worst case
error but you know that's a good way to
good place to look right
um and so so maybe similar types of
constructions or or
somehow other inspired by this result
would let us find codes that actually
can kind of push the quantum channel
capacity
maybe even well beyond what we can do
right now and uh and and maybe even you
know help us understand actually what
the actual upper limit is
to super additivity of channel capacity
that would be that would be great
so so if you were interested
only in
random errors is there much better
much simpler construction of quantum
ldpc codes
um i mean so the the the square root of
addin
uh you know hypergraph product codes
that's already good enough for for
correcting typical errors um
uh it's it's possible and again we don't
because we don't have all the decoders
worked out but it's possible that these
linear distance codes could do better in
terms of threshold um but it's possible
they're not right so it's this is
another class of
of questions that still need to be
answered
can i make it can i make a comment too
um probably because i feel like there's
like way too much agreement on this
panel and always we should have a little
disagreement on the panel but uh i want
to um you know barbara and daniel are
both saying threshold is important and
that's definitely incredibly important
but i just want to like emphasize one of
the reasons i think that distance is
also very important
which is that if you're
significantly below threshold which is
where you would like to operate because
you wouldn't want to operate near
threshold because then your code sizes
will be
enormous
and you're interested in
very low logical error rates you might
really be worrying about things that are
errors that are occurring close to the
minimum distance you might be wanting to
operate your code in the regime where
the most likely error is a minimum
distance error rather than a typical
error um
and um so i think i think you know this
i you know i'm kind of coming around to
more and that that
maybe this linear distance really is an
advantage you know at first you think oh
this is rare errors but we might if we
want to get
uh you know logical error rates of 10 to
the minus 15 or something we need to be
dealing with that and we don't want to
be close to threshold
that's that's true but in the spirit of
disagreement
um i the the
you know you need you kind of need both
i mean so if you can keep the threshold
and improve the minimum distance i think
that's true but if it's a matter of
trading off threshold versus minimum
distance well
you still have to be some distance below
the threshold right and so if the
threshold is higher for the same
physical error rate you're going to be
further below the threshold if the
threshold is higher
so i mean obviously you have to look at
kind of all the spectrum codes you have
available and
put everything together and all your
fault tolerant protocols to see what's
actually the best thing to do but i
agree that that there will be some
regimes where a linear distance code is
better but
you know depending on what code's
available there are also regimes where
it's not
yeah i mean i agree like for a lot of a
lot of codes like a heuristic for the
logical error rate which works kind of
reasonably well is the logical error
rate is
physical error rate divided by threshold
raised to the distance on two
i mean you should correct it a little
bit but that's kind of like your first
back of the envelope so yeah they
clearly both matter
yeah and i i think i think i stressed uh
threshold because that is a current
bottleneck in terms of experimental
progress because it's just incredibly
hard to get
error rates of 10 minus three or
something it's in a scalable manner
right everybody knows this otherwise our
field would have progressed much faster
i mean
so it's just focusing on the most uh
relevant bottleneck it's not um yeah but
another another point i wanted to make
is is maybe this is actually a question
to anthony
um
so so i think it's also interesting to
have concrete uh constructive um
constructions right so not just
randomized constructions of the
existence of code families
um
can you comment on that because there i
know there are some constructions but
not all of them are
explicit
um
constructions that you could you know
test for
a threshold or do other numerics on and
also small constructions would be
interesting
yeah so for the new codes for the
quantum intellectuals
i mean it's very easy to
look at explicit examples so you just
need to look at you need a group with
two subsets so any group
will do um
and you need a small code so the id so i
mean if you want the synthetic results
you want to take large small codes which
we behave like typical random codes
um
but if you want small examples you could
take you know um
[Music]
classical codes of length seven um
and you know like uh
[Music]
uh bch code
and like this that have distance free
and that you are you know so you need
both the code and its dual to have large
distance
um but you can do that with you know
small cause of length seven um and then
okay so then you it means that you
and then you yeah okay you take any
group that you want so it's very easy to
get small examples uh with like about
400 cubic cubits
you can have a dimension that is not too
bad
a few tens
but for for this size of codes you know
the the scaling of the distance
uh it won't show up and you you still
get small distances so the
the
kind of the point where you the regime
where you you start beating you know the
square root and distance probably you
have to go higher with this construction
you probably need a few thousands of
cubits tens of ten thousand cubes i
don't know
um so it's easy to to divide you know
small examples a few few hundred qubits
uh
this won't have like a great some
distance uh not too bad but not right
if you want better distance you need
longer credits
or better constructions
[Music]
yeah so i guess i i don't have a good
overview of all the constructions but i
think that is also sort of maybe a
challenge to
to that that you would like to have good
small constructions for if you want to
study some properties that
may be relevant practically right
yeah of course yeah
yes
i'd have a sort of naive question for
you uh daniel in in in the fault
tolerance construction with uh you know
quantum ldpc codes
so
uh
what is the level of parallelism that
you can achieve in
in uh in applying gates you know so now
you have n qubits or some constant times
n qubits encoded in this in this code
and now how what are you doing under the
covers with it
um so there's a trade-off
um
so um
you need
basically you need sub-linear
parallelism
um so there's a okay so the way the way
my construction works which probably is
not the only way or the best way to do
it but it's just a way that is easy to
prove
um
is is instead of using one giant code to
encode your whole computation
is to use smaller blocks of sublinear
size
and the reason for that is that when you
want to do gates you need kind of
additional
ancillas that are the size of a block
actually they are a block um with you
know ancillary qubit logical and
silicubits
um
and
um so there's a there's a trade-off then
because if you want to do gates you have
to the size of the block times the
amount of parallelism you have that's
kind of the number of ventilators that
you need
um and so
if you want more
um parallelism you can decrease the size
of the block further
and then you can have more logical gates
in parallel but the problem is that when
you decrease the size of the block
you'll get um slower
scaling of everything else and
protecting against arrows so you
probably have to push up to bigger and
bigger sizes
um before
um before it it actually becomes it
makes it work right there's some like
threshold value
uh size threshold size where you can say
well the overhead is less than this
amount
um
but but in principle you can do that for
any
uh sublinear amount of parallelism
um now again there may be some totally
different approach that doesn't have
this problem and lets you do linear
parallelism that's another open question
that's very interesting
so i i had a question
or comment
i actually have several questions but
let me start with one i'm curious if
there might be um
thinking out of the box in many ways
these ldpc calls which i'm very excited
by are not very exciting to the
experimentalists because they're very
worried about the
high connectivity that may be required
between qubits in these systems
so um more realistically to many of the
my colleagues doing experiment are
specialized error correction codes which
are much more quantum in many ways
bosonic error correction codes error
correction calls for geo is just
erasure for example
so
are there going to be does this inspire
you to think of
truly quantum codes that have really
very little connection with classical
error correction
uh and and calls which dominantly handle
one kind of error like
a quantum erasure error or amplitude
damping
um so okay so first of all
i don't think you can ever get away from
codes that uh are totally different than
classical codes i mean
even even like ekp codes for bozonic
things those are those have a classical
analog which is just discretizing
things
um
it's and um
i i mean i'm i'm always a little kind of
wary of codes that kind of predominantly
only create one kind of error because in
a real system there's many kinds of
errors and maybe one of them is bigger
and so it's worth having codes that are
better at feeding one kind of error but
you know once you knock it down even
just a little bit you'll start to get
other kinds of errors i think and you're
really gonna have to deal with a broad
spectrum um and moreover
um
the
the process of making it fall tolerant
you just don't know how to deal with
most kinds of errors there's specific
kinds like dephasing there's been a lot
of progress
on dealing with defacing errors fall
tolerantly
our ratio errors happen to be pretty
easy to deal with fault tolerantly they
require like the same thing but almost
anything else like amplitude damping
have no idea how to try to do that
without just correcting everything
um
that's something that we might see
progress in soon who knows but
um
um and the i mean i think i think the
important thing to to remember is that
this is like a really hard problem in
general dealing with the fault tolerance
dealing with errors and we're kind of
just going to be throwing everything we
have at it
for the next couple of decades maybe um
and so i mean if you talk about bosonic
codes
typically people are not thinking that
the bosonic code is just all they have
to do right they're going to concatenate
that bosonic code with some other code
or maybe some some other kind of hybrid
code like that
um
so
you know there's there's a lot of tricks
and
just get to get back to your very first
point about the connectivity that's
obviously a really important question
um these these high rate ldpc codes
cannot be embedded in in finite
dimensions
but um
there are some implementations where
that's not such a big constraint like
photonic ones or or even ion traps where
you have smaller traps connected by you
know long-range things
um
and moreover i mean
it's logically possible that we can
somehow fit these ldpc codes into two
dimensions with only kind of a limited
amount of long-range connectivity and
get around that and still
um and still be able to do error
correction and fall tolerance that's
that's like pure speculation but i have
a student looking at that and it
it might be possible
so that would be c5 codes with low
connectivity or something
i i i mean who knows right it's too
early to to really say but yeah so um
so i don't think the the low
connectivity is necessarily i mean the
high connectivity needed is necessarily
a deal breaker um but obviously it's a a
drawback of of these codes versus
surface code and that will continue to
be true presumably even if we come up
with you know otherwise practical
protocols
another another question is i i have no
good ideas about this is but
it's besides connectivity it's the other
parameters of the codes are you know
what's the parity check weights and uh
what's the degree yes so how many parity
checks does every qubit participate in
and as far as i can tell there are no
sort of no go results there
that say i mean there are some no-go
results so very low you know
parody check weight too and so on you
can't make a code but but it's not like
um
you know you can say well how far can we
minimize these weights
and i know people have tried to do that
in some constructions
but um
yeah so i wonder also about optimizing
that what are the possibilities there
or showing that it's not possible
because that's another
experimental constraint of course
yeah every
any ldpc
code
could be made i forget exactly what the
numbers but the parity check weights and
stuff can somewhere it's like around
five to eight or something you can make
them all like not some ridiculously big
number even if they start as some really
big number if it starts okay they can
get the sun
you can make them fi wait five you're
saying or something like that i forget
the exact number somewhere in that range
and then you look you just uh the
distance and the there is still constant
factors yeah there's some constant loss
no the constant factor loss depends upon
what they were initially so if initially
they were you know a million when you
get down to five you only lose a
constant factor in the distance yeah so
you're okay yeah
but then the other degree is also
included yeah they can be some some
number around there forget the exact
number
thanks
i want to poke another hole if if
there's time for me to ask one more
um how about non-stabilizer codes i
still really love these new dimensions
that are coming out like that started
with i mean
cws clothes were one of them but it
seems to have grown
do you have optimism about that
direction
anyone on the panel
well for what purpose right i think you
know for mathematical studies or
interest i think anything goes if it's i
think it's fascinating but uh
yeah
or specifically
uh i i don't know a single tolerant
construction for those and i'm i've
always been curious to even come up with
one
because
maybe then it would be something that's
uniquely quantum and and not not
terribly classical
all right so um i of course have a
conflict of interest with having
optimism about non-stabilizer codes but
um i mean i let me the one the one
family i think that that has some
clear value fall tolerantly is not a
billion antions which don't have any
stabilizer realization
but clearly you know provide some degree
of fault tolerance although not
necessarily everything you want
and the motivation there would be these
kinds of codes might lead to
hamiltonians which then give you a sense
of some natural stability
like you say
yeah although i mean if they don't
actually right just like this the the
torque code doesn't actually provide
self-correction but you know maybe
there's some higher dimensional um
you know four four-dimensional
non-abelian uh
things with strings and
walls and stuff like that that that does
do that
well or at least in the cws code
you need only use one classical code for
the construction
and then it has to correct these uh
other strange patterns of errors because
of this xz duality that a an x error
turns into a a higher weight z error for
example
and
then maybe there could be new ldpc
constructions made from sophisticated
classical codes that correct multiple
errors
i mean honestly i'm not completely sure
how you would define a non-stabilizer
ldpc code i mean
you can you can come up with definitions
but
it's
not there's not like an obviously
correct one
um
any other questions from the audience
in the meantime uh let me let me ask um
uh anthony you may have touched on this
already but um
[Music]
was you know was there a sense of
was it just a big coincidence that um
you know that that classical
you know
locally
locally testable codes sort of coincided
with this quantum ldpc code so is it
was that a coincidence or was it is
there something more basic going on
there
very good
question probably you would have to ask
you know yourselves a little papers
um
[Music]
yeah i mean you know i mean the fact
that
these chronometers with good distance
they give you
so it's not necessary to always but for
all the constructions that we know they
give you you know
classical local testable codes
yeah it's a bit surprising i don't know
if people
i mean i don't know
about the left and gates have noticed
that because yeah and inside you can see
that some of the ltcs they are hidden
somewhere but you have to look for them
um
yeah i don't know um
i don't know
i mean okay so for the cause that we
that we have so
um
it's kind of so we were
with so with gil zamori we are looking
at
we are trying to find a decoder for the
the code of ponte and kalashev and
and while we are trying to do that so
now we found ways to simplify the
curtain
and little by little we came closer and
closer to the to the dining retail
construction and at the end we realized
okay there and the generated constraint
is hidden just here so so we went from
the
russian code to the
code
because we are looking for decoder
and insight maybe it's kind of obvious
that these two things are related but
but
it's not clear to me anyone you know
that it's that they are connected
i mean at some point i knew how to
to prove i mean it was the the local
stability it's just a corollary of our
results um
but then so we wrote the proof and then
a couple of weeks later i wanted to
remember and i couldn't remember how it
goes so
so it's there but it's not so trivial
the connection is not so so easy to to
spot so i don't know what the
hf and
the code
this connection
but it's very intriguing that there is
this connection
yeah
extremely new
um
so any other any other comments from the
panel or any other questions
there's a question in the q a
okay
okay
the question says any
comments
on the potential impact that emerging
fields such as
multiple theory type theory could have
in the future of quantum computation
to know if somebody wants to
danielle did you want to address that
no i have no idea i was hoping matt or
anthony
or barbara or anybody else would have an
answer on that
no answer
okay
um
okay so uh any anything else that
anyone on the panel wants to say
any last thoughts
otherwise um
well uh
again let's uh thank uh anthony for a
fantastic talk and panel for really
great
discussion and
we'll see you next week
okay thank you
anthony daniel barker and matt
thanks